hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hello neighbor now
you may be wondering didn't died what
issue it was not meant as an insult I'm
assuming you have coherent thoughts
inside your head unlike myself but there
was an update to the game as with every
update to this game they add more stuff
to the neighbor's house and they take
away stuff from mine I can't even go in
my own front door anymore
that's how limited I am now but I just
wanted to do a quick okay hi what are
you doing okay you were gliding for a
little bit there you were gliding and I
didn't know why and you've got a
flashlight I don't know why alright you
carry on I'm gonna do something
apparently hidey-ho neighbor you're
you're you're doing lovely here hey hi
hello hi hello
okay alright
see ya dude watch out for traffic over
there are you going why oh why do I get
such an uneasy feeling when I'm crawling
up your backside where are you going
ah just taking in the view I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're caressing over
there what are you doing Oh alrighty
then hey Lee ho neighbor hi good to see
you I'm new in the neighborhood you want
to be friends
whoa whoa oh [ __ ] okay because they got
in his face a little too much and he
finally noticed me alright but anyway
there's there's new levels to this and I
can already see that they took out the
ladder those connected to the second
floor over there so I'm going to go in
here and also now the game runs like a
potato I don't know if that's by design
or not hello
squeak hello hi anybody here
[Music]
yes that's the same how do I pick there
we go alright I'm just assuming that
everything is generally the same so I'm
going to the mannequin looks a little
worse for wear but okay I'm gonna assume
that everything's fine hideki oh hey can
I get out okay alrighty then
just operating it what is that hello
them to be from Naboo knew that the
elevator
whew hi no no no come on no you don't
want to mess with me come on
oh [ __ ] hell this car is it travel
down here yeah yeah see ya
you stay on your hey [ __ ] ah I don't
know where I went but it was fun
alright let me see if the magneto is
still where the magneto think he clunky
it's gonna be it is a lot more [ __ ]
one you didn't notice nothing and I
don't know why you thumpy thump away oh
uh either way the magnitude oh oh hey oh
hi okay never mind then goodbye la la la
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah that's right yeah yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah you better watch out for
the traffic here it's pretty brutal
alright okay so basically it's kind of
the same as it was except the magnet
isn't so obviously placed let me just be
a little more sneaky about this Oh bear
trap that didn't hurt say what I don't
understand is like with all that they've
done in terms of adding to the game they
haven't added any purpose to it why am i
risking life and limb breaking into this
guy's house just seems a little bit
unnecessary if you ask me I'm gonna try
to make this stupid jump that I hate oh
there we go whoa see it is the same so
you do need a magnet there's something
else in that room too oh wait the
magnets right there what but that
doesn't make any sense how would you be
able to get over there if you needed the
magnet there and the key is there why
and how are you gonna get me huh loser
ah nerd Oh what was that also well I
don't know oh hi are you gonna do I can
do buddy huh yeah you don't know what to
do and lick my legs so how in the world
how in the wide world are you supposed
to be able to number one get that magnet
right there which you might be able to
sneak in and get it from like if you
were in there but as far as I know that
is the room where you need the blue key
so it's all kind of conundrum as' if you
ask me just a little bit conundrum is
school oh that's weird
why are those on the ceiling and why are
they staring at me got to be something
to do with more the base level stuff
except kids toy is that an actual
lawnmower I don't know what that was and
I don't know where he was but he was
nearby ooh all right it's fine it's fine
so if I leap in here whoa bad timing on
that low high that was weird yeah
whoa oh well he's in a run today tonight
oh boy oh boy he's sprinting around
outside ah you got me
whoa hi I'm in so now I like I'm really
puzzled here because you got to be able
to get up to the second floor like
that's paramount you have to be able to
get up to the second floor right Ryan I
don't know what that powered down but
gotta be some way that does not involve
me stacking a bunch of [ __ ] and
climbing up there because that's not
what I want to do is now how I spend my
time maybe there's some way that I could
stack boxes here a wool oh I know
ah glue ah very sticky glue it's great I
love it but just don't do it again
there's my flashlight that I'm else
wired and a mist oh oh no wow man man me
and his home whole nother set of secrets
in here and I don't know if I have the
patience to find them God if there are
new things though like that's farther up
and out I mean I was able to go down the
street maybe I could go over to a
neighbor's house Hey hi did you know
you're in never mind you have an
invisible force field okay bye
how about you I'm new here I mean okay
hi my friend Hey
[Music]
you're happy and you know it what when I
was in the road you rude person you why
oh oh he's getting real sensitive around
here oh I might as well just earn your
game okay I'm gonna do that hee hee hee
hee ha ha that's something they added oh
yeah I didn't show you guys the we're
the intro sequence like I don't know if
this door is the sound of someone trying
to get in or get out and also was he
crying up there on that balcony there I
have no idea I really don't know hello
crow oh [ __ ]
I've already been startled by that so
don't even try it again what is that
Russian I just don't understand
I wish I understood and then you get a
letter I don't know why why do you get
letter I don't know so I'm gonna sneak
this he's he hasn't spotted me and he
hasn't gotten me so I'm assuming that
I'm gonna be able to get in here
do all these funky dumb things to all my
own frivolity so as far as I know he's
going down to the end of the street
because who would think that someone
would be breaking into their house at
this point probably not him oh oh whoa
that is not what I thought it'd be Oh Oh
aah
nothing's wrong nothing is wrong you
can't see anything behind these boxes ok
so there's a green key here and there's
something in this room I mean obviously
it's the way to go in from outside but
there's something here so is there a
green key before the blue key that's
what I would like to know
oops well that's an example of fit wait
wait
thought for a second there for like a
second that opened up no all right I'm
guessing that it so there's gotta be
some other words oh oh oh
open open open open oh oh why why why
why what what what okay all right that
sucked but okay all right I'll take it
Oh hmm okay
so I don't know the deeper mysteries of
this new version there may be secrets
lurking in those upstairs rooms that
didn't exist before and also what is
with that weird long what is with this
what is with all this what is this part
of his house what that doesn't make any
sense why is this here oh this just
doesn't make any sense
I mean it'd be easy enough to just build
a tower and try to climb up that way but
that's [ __ ] and you I don't want to
do that I do at the corner quote a
legitimate way so if you guys know where
these new keys are and if there's a
secret worth seeing up there oh let me
know frying gram by Knox hmm
I've got all your secrets in my bag good
all right you go live your life so if
you guys know the secrets to his house
or at least how to get started try not
to spoil too much for me but let me know
down the comments below if there's
something worth seeing and pursuing
because I'm gonna have to face this
house with fear and frustration in my
soul and I will only go in there if I'm
willing to beat it so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
in the next video by
[Music]